in this lecture we introduced Markov
chains a general class of random
processes with many applications dealing
with the evolution of dynamical systems
as opposed to the Bernoulli and Poisson
processes which are memoryless in the
sense that the future does not depend on
the past Markov chains are more
elaborate as they allow some
dependencies between different times
however these dependencies are of simple
and restricted nature captured by the so
called Markov property conditional on
the current state of a Markov chain its
future and past evolutions are
independent as mentioned in the unit
overview we will only consider
discrete-time markov chains that evolve
within finite state spaces this allows
us to concentrate on the main concepts
without having to deal with some
required technical details needed to
study general McCaw processes and the
continuous time and general possibly
uncountable state spaces we will first
introduce the basic concepts using the
simple example of a checkout counter at
a supermarket an example of a simple
queueing system we will then abstract
from the example and give some general
definitions including the central
notions of states transition
probabilities Markov property and
transition probability graphs afterwards
we will look at various questions such
as predicting what would happen in n
steps in the future given the current
state of our system we will define and
step transition probabilities exactly
and show how to calculate them
efficiently we will also discuss what
could happen when we let a Markov chain
run for a very long time we will end
this lecture by introducing the notions
of recurrent and transient States and
their importance in studying markov
chains in the long-run